ja also ich begrüße ganz herzlich zur
heutigen sitzung in der wir uns
beginnend mit dem trieb begriff
beschäftigen werden letzte sitzung ist
ausgefallen wie sie bestimmen im
sap-system gesehen haben oder sonst eben
gemerkt haben als sie hier vor einem
leeren raum standen
was hat es mit dem begriff des triebes
aufsicht das ist ein ganz interessantes
thema wurde ganz selten bisher gemacht
vertrieb ist etwas dunkles wir reden
gleich noch über den trieb begriff trieb
das ist ein bisschen verruf geraten seit
sigmund freud triebhafte menschen sind
problematische menschen
viel eher ist der begriff der freiheit
jetzt zentral geworden begriff des
willens und viele allem konkurrieren der
begriffe wir wollen uns aber ganz
bewusst mit dem begriff des triebes
beschäftigen und mit dem begriff des
triebes in einer bestimmten
philosophischen epoche nämlich derjenige
klassischen deutschen philosophie da
muss ich auch noch kurz etwas dazu sagen
ja was in die leitfragen des seminares
also wir wollen uns fragen wie wir der
ursprünglich biologische begriff des
triebes von leibnitz bisherige leibnitz
wird immer ein bisschen anklingen wir
werden uns aber vor allem auch härter
als dem ersten philosophie beziehen für
sophies geprägt und systematisch
einbezogen in die jeweiligen systeme
dann kann man sich fragen welche rolle
spielt dieser begriff des tri wissen der
jeweiligen theoretischen und in der
praktischen philosophie kann ich schon
vorwegnehmen der begriff des triebes
deswegen so interessant weil er die
grenzen von theoretischer philosophie
und praktische philosophie also
handlungs theorie überbrückt als er
trieb ist so eine art smiley these wir
können darüber diskutieren sind einheits
begriff der trieb erlaubt es als begriff
die einheit von theorie also von
erkennen und von handeln zu leisten dass
es glaube ich so eine mögliche
interpretation weise diese streep ist
streep begriffs wohl nehmen uns immer
fragen warum beziehen sich die
philosophen sind leider nur männer
muss ich sagen wenn ihnen da noch eine
frau bekannt ist die da auch etwas
interessantes zum trieb begriff gesagt
hat dürfen sie das jederzeit einbringen
ja vielleicht kenne ich sie noch nicht
also wir wollen uns nicht nur fragen was
haben die jeweiligen philosophen darüber
gesagt sind wurde uns immer auch immer
frage warum haben sie das gesagt und ist
das war sie darüber sagen überhaupt
relevant ist es überzeugend wie verhält
sich das zu dem was andere davor oder
danach dazu gesagt haben und dann wollen
wir uns fragen was sagt das uns für die
heutige zeit können wir heute immer noch
so über den trieb begriff reden
also das ist die frage inwiefern ist
hier auch der begriff des lebens im
spiel der durch dass der begriff des
lebens denn durch den trieb begriff
genauer bestimmt wird
das scheint mir auch noch ein zentraler
punkt zu sein
ja und dann worin besteht die aktualität
und worin bestehen die grenzen dieser
jeweiligen theorien als meine seminare
sind immer historisch systematisch
aufgebaut das heißt wir wollen wissen
was haben da leute früher darüber gesagt
geschrieben
wir wollen immer diskutieren ist das was
die gesagt und geschrieben haben auch
irgendwie heute noch relevant bringt uns
das was ist es nur was was wir in so ein
museum stellen können also der tri
begriff von iks der trieb begriff von y
dass diese begriffe stellen wären ein
museum und betrachten das von außen und
genießen das ist ethisch das ist glaube
ich eine seite der sache aber wir wollen
uns immer auf frage was können wir
konkret damit anfangen ja ziele in fast
voller machen eben wie schon sagt
historisch systematisch die bedeutung
diskutieren
den trieb begriff von anderen verwandten
begriffen abgrenzen entwicklungslinien
und tendenzen erkennbar werden lassen
die klassische dort klassische deutsche
philosophie kennen lernen
ich sage bewusst die klassische deutsche
philosophie ich sag nicht der deutsche
idealismus wenn es dann noch einen
unterschied gibt genau das sind so die
ziele und ich kann jetzt schon sagen sie
finden die folien an alle auch im
internet als brauchen sich da jetzt
keine sorgen
dazu machen sie
finden die alle gleich im internet und
ich sag jetzt was zur anlage dieses
seminars wer schon einmal von ihr weiß
war weiß dass ich hier so einen youtube
kanal heißt philo kaarst er hat jetzt
schon über tausend abonnenten sind wir
sehr stolz drauf und sie sehen hier jede
menge videos wir kamen kürzlich im radio
studenten radio m 490 5 und sie werden
dann demnächst vielleicht sogar schon
heute oder morgen die aufnahme der
heutigen sitzung als podcast als audio
podcast auf viele cast finden
zum nachhören vielleicht auch mit diesen
folien ich schaue ob ich die folien da
auch noch mit dazu nehmen sie können
gerne abonnieren würde uns freuen
schauen sie mal vorbei und das ist nicht
alles und wir haben auch eine eigene app
für smartphones und für android und so
sieht sie aus sie können sie sich gerne
herunterladen jetzt sie dürfen auch
gerne immer im seminar ihre smartphones
auf dem tisch haben
ich zeige euch mal wie das aussieht so
sieht's aus es läuft wurde schon
abgestürzt nägel jetzt noch hat schon
gezeigt ja sehen sie denn hier können
sie hier sehr schön in den ganzen
seminaren sozusagen scrollen und eben
sich da orientieren das ist glaube ich
mal was neues
so sieht dann das inhaltsverzeichnis
ausgesehen denn hier das aktuelle
seminar sind auch andere seminare die
angeboten habe anbieten und so sehen
dann diese einträge aus
jedes seminar eine andere farbe ja ich
glaub trieb ist diesmal wieder rot ich
hatte mal was das unmoralische angebote
da war es auch rot so können sich
orientieren können sich gerne
runterladen ist kostenlos
jetzt habe ich hier eine ganz
interessante grafik und zwar ist das amt
idee was das ist
was könnte das sein
ja
genau also das völlig richtig nicht die
anzahl zwar nur die prozentuale
verhältnisse also es nicht ist es nicht
genau gesagt wie viele jetzt nennungen
da sind aber sie sehen hier eine
zeitleiste von 1600 bis 2000
und sie sehen hier gibt es irgendwie so
ein höhepunkt für gipfel so und 1750 bis
1800 herum
da wird er kommt der begriff des triebes
oder das wort trieb muss man genauer
gesagt sagen das wird viele sehr häufig
haben hier genannt sie kommt sehr häufig
von literatur und tier sehen sie die
prozentualen verhältnisse also zwischen
0,01 und 0,06 prozent aller vorkommnisse
vor allem wörter oder begriffe sind
trieb es ganz interessant man darf jetzt
nicht so viel drauf geben das ist eben
das corpus also alle verfügbaren texte
von google google hat ziemlich viele
texte digitalisiert aus diesen jahren
das wissen sie
und mit ocr optical character
recognition software erkannt können sie
mal googeln und sie sehen hier das ganze
feld ab in der zweiten hälfte des 19
jahrhunderts und wird immer seltener
gebraucht bis in die gegenwart hinein
aber es gab ja so ein paar besonders
häufige verwendung zeiten und mit diesen
zeiten beschäftigen wir uns gerade als
1750 bis ungefähr 1840 30 schopenhauer
so 20.30 so bis dahin wird betrachten
diesen zeit diesen zeitraum betrachten
wie
zimmer ganz interessante könnte das ist
der google brumby uhr
ich schreibe es mal hin ich weiß nicht
genau was das jetzt heißt ich glaube so
sieht das aus wenn google können sie mal
mit anderen wörtern auch mal versuchen
das ist also ganz interessant was sie
dann dafür grafiken erhalten dass wir
als motivation es gibt eine gewisse
entwicklung so und hatte ich auch schon
in der ankündigung des seminars hatte
ich darauf hingewiesen dass es eine
internationale tagung gab die hat schon
stattgefunden über den konzept das
konzept des triebes der klassischen
deutschen philosophie mit we are change
ecology and physics also der trieb
begriff steht zwischen biologie
anthropologie und metaphysik und wenn
sie sich die vorträge in den
kurzfassungen nochmal anschauen wollen
können sie auf diese homepage gehen
greift diesen punkt nett und wenn sie
sich einige der vorträge nach sehen
wollen die haben nämlich aufgezeichnet
können sie auf meinen kanal viel lowcost
gehen und da finden sie die dann in
gänze teilweise auch mit folien mit
powerpoint folie und da werden auch noch
weitere darauf gestellt ich bin noch
nicht ganz fertig mit dieser aufnahme
genau schauen sie mal vorbei wer von
ihnen wartet auf der tagung einfach mal
melden ja 34 genau schauen sie einfach
mal vorbei
das ist also ziemlich begleitend zum
seminar wir werden in diesem seminar
eigentlich mehr oder weniger genau
dieselben den kaffeehandel die auch auf
dieser tagung behandelt worden
jetzt gibt es ja ein begriffliches
umfeld des triebes jetzt möchte ich sie
mal ein bisschen aktivieren welche
begriffe fallen in den 1
die ähnlich sind wie der begriff des
triebes haben sie das ein paar ideen was
könnte man noch so nennen wenn man jetzt
hier so mal trieb
trieb und begriffen etwas gibt es eben
für ähnliche begriffe die zwei komplette
antrieb
ja
es muss also nicht immer was betrieb
direkte begriff tree das wort trieb muss
nicht drin sein
ganz sind mir motivation drang und
instinkt ja noch weitere streben
appetit ja genau also diese appetitlos
rational ist vielleicht haben sie das
schon mal gehört das ist eine wendung
die kommt in mittelalterlichen denken
sie häufig vor
das ist praktisch dieses begehrens oder
strebe vermögen und das strebe vermögen
kann rational oder kann auch irrational
sein haben sie sonst noch weitere ein
ganz wichtiger begriff ist jetzt noch
nicht gefallen ein ganz wichtiger
kraft ja
herr wollen genau oder der wille ich
schreib mal hinwill
genau das ist auch wichtig sonst so was
ja die video ja das ist also das
triebhafte er
haben wir schon genau tragen haben wir
das geht so ein bisschen diese richtung
höher
da haben wir einige und jetzt würde ich
sie mal fragen was spricht denn jetzt
dagegen trieb mit bille gleichzusetzen
warum würden sie jetzt sagen trieb muss
von wille unterschieden werden
bewusst und hier häufig unbewusst oder
man könnte auch sagen der wille ist mit
vernunft verwoben
der wille ist mit vernunft verhält sich
zur vernunft der wille kann vernünftig
bestimmt sein
der tri bis häufig fast irrationalen sie
noch freiheit ja genau
genau also der bewusste wille ist häufig
der freie wille warum weil ich bin ich
mir meines willens meines wollens
bewusst bin dass wollen auch bestimmen
kann in welche richtung ich jetzt was
ich jetzt entscheide entscheidungen ich
habe verschiedene strömungen in mir
vielleicht auch verschieden triebe ich
will dass ich will dass ich spüre mehr
antrieb dahin ich spüre mehr antrieb
dahin
und jetzt muss ich von einer höheren
ebene bewusst frei mich entscheiden
welchem trieb gebe ich jetzt den vorzug
ich habe hunger ich habe lust auf das
was zu essen ich habe auch ein bedürfnis
nach jetzt hier zu unterrichten oder was
zu lernen
dann muss ich abwägen muss ich sagen was
ist jetzt angesichts der umstände
wichtiger für mich was ist besser was
ist sinnvoll und dann werden die
verschiedenen triebe oder motivationen
oder willens tendenzen oder was auch
immer
die werden dann zu möglichen
handlungsoptionen zu gewissen möglichen
gründen der delegation
als motiv habe ich jetzt hier bei wille
streben hatte ich mir überlegt gefühl
das ist vertrieb ein gefühl natur
vernunft leben und so weiter aber sie
haben glaube ich noch bessere genannten
also wähle finde ich auch sehr zentral
das sind jetzt so die begriffe fällt die
noch eine eigene zu denen die wir hier
in der tafel haben oder hier auf den
folien ja vielleicht könnte es ein
bisschen erklären
ja wir können es wir können uns gerne
gerne mit aufnehmen
[Musik]
ja wir könnten da auch noch denkt ich
handlung mit aufnehmen also ist nicht
natürlich nicht er trieb aber der
betrieb will zu einer handlung führen
auch der wille der trieb treibt uns zu
einer handlung
ja
das ist jetzt wie gesagt nicht
abgeschlossen gab es noch eine meldung
ja es war
ja wunsch wunsch oder begehren haben wir
begehren schon noch nicht glauben
begehren das sind auch gleich bei der
libido
genau und ich denke was ganz wichtig ist
es dass man den trieb ja auch mit kraft
ein bisschen in verbindung bringt also
er trieb ist so eine art basis so könnte
man es dann auch wieder mit dem prinzip
in verbindung bringen das ist alles ein
lebensprinzip vielleicht ist etwas was
uns energie gibt energie wäre auch noch
so was nur energie
energie oder wirklichkeit auch sie
wirklichkeit wirklichkeit
zum beispiel können sie jetzt trieb von
vorstellungen unterscheiden
meine vorstellung ist was bloß
abstraktes und die vorstellung oder kein
ziel
um die zu verwirklichen brauche ich
einen antrieb und das könnte zum
beispiel antrieb sein also wirklichkeit
wäre es bloß möglich kann ich kann mir
alles mögliche vorstellen aber ich muss
es auch mal verwirklichen und dazu
brauche ich keine kraft zum prinzip der
kraft und das wird bei vielen der denken
die wir jetzt hier behandelt werden in
dem semester der fall sein also trieb
ist eine energiequelle
aber das problem ist natürlich diese
energiequelle es recht obskur wissen
nicht woher betrieb kommt wir wissen
nicht woher der trieb uns führt wo
hinter trieb uns führt woher wohin das
ist alles ein bisschen offen und im
idealfall ist der trip etwas dem wir
zügeln den wir also im griff wir müssen
unsere triebe im griff haben müssen die
zügel bändigen
es gibt da von platon eine ganz schöne
stelle
kennen sie das bei platon wer hatte den
vortrag von herrn zöller gehört ich
verlinke ihn dann im video oben rechts
auf youtube an
genau hier genau dieser wagen linker das
ist ein plan den platonischen wer kommt
es vor dass verschiedene triebe und die
triebe sind wir besser zu verstehen
ein rost zieht nach links 1 nach rechts
und wir müssen sagen über den trieben
stehen oder hinter ihnen wie auch immer
müssen die zügel anlegen diesen triebe
müssen sie beherrschen müssen sie
kontrollieren
und da kommt dann hier das bewusstsein
die freiheit ein
reflexion herrn platon selbst spricht
noch nicht von von freiheit in diesem
sinne aber es ist so ein gewisses modell
von freiheit denke ich kann man sich
überlegen ja also das ist so der kontext
und jetzt möchte ich ihnen ganz kurz zum
einstieg hier ein überblick gebieten
über die behandelten denker wir beginnen
mit diesem herrn hier wissen sie wer das
ist hertha ihren gottfried herder 1744
1803 und hertha hat eine
geschichtsphilosophie entwickelt in der
sich die menschheit fortentwickelt also
also ein sehr fortschrittliches anliegen
und her da sieht die menschliche
entwicklung einer gewissen kontinuität
zur natürlichen entwicklung also wie
sich etwas organisch entwickelt wird das
aufblüht dass die natur so entwickelt
sich auch die menschheit zur vernunft
hin natürlich auch der
aufklärungsgedanke ganz stark im
hintergrund und ist eine eine idee hat
seine hat ideen zur geschichte der
menschheit geschrieben und darin kommt
eben auch der trieb ganz prominent vor
das ist praktisch dieses antriebsmoment
was eine menschliche entwicklung zur
aufklärung hinbewegt motiv und da kommt
dann vielleicht wieder das prinzip zur
geltung
es ist ein prinzip ist etwas was der
entwicklung zugrunde liegt diese
energiequelle
natürlich kann man sich jetzt fragen
woher hat der trieb seine richtung ist
der trieb nicht nur blind mit könnten
vielleicht ja auch noch mal unbewusst
und blind hinschreiben und wir haben ja
noch neigungen neigungen habe ich hier
noch nicht begehren und neigung die
neigung das auch noch so was hat in
krina zion kannte man erkannt wird von
neigungen sprechen also hier können sie
sich merken aufklärung geschichte der
menschheit und entwicklung der
menschheit das ist in die drei
schlagworte zu hertha
da in dieser entwicklung zur aufklärung
hin zur vernunft da spielt der trieb
eine ganze rolle sie mit tun haben ich
habe mit dieser annahme kommen wir da
unten ja das ist das steht hier schon
aber der ganze namen haben sie nicht
dass die johann friedrich blumenbach
schöne blume da ist auch was von seiner
philosophie enthalten nämlich wissen sie
es noch von der tagung welcher begriff
hiermit blumenbach ganz eng verbunden
ist
das ist der bildung streep noch im
weiteren begriff haben wir jetzt hier
bildung bildung bildung bildung strip
bildung kann man auf verschiedene weise
verstehen also jemand ist gebildet man
kann aber auch bildung so verstehen dass
sich etwas ausgestaltet ausdifferenziert
ausbildet organisch auch das ist
vielleicht auch noch wichtiger prüfen
organismus das ist jetzt nicht direkt
dazu aber finde ich auch noch wichtig
organismen also bei organismen haben wir
es häufig mit trieb legten dingen zu tun
die nach dem gewissen muster sich
entwickeln auch so was eine blüte haben
also sich völlig entfalten also die
entfaltung und dass dieser bildung
streep also bildungsoffensive sich so
verstehen dass jemand hier ganz begierig
ist sich zu bilden und welche bücher
liest wie sie jetzt an studieren da ist
so ein bildungsziel bisschen noch viel
natürlicher gefasst silvia natürlichen
aus die fraktion aber natürlich kann man
dann diesen bildung streep auch auf den
menschen anwenden auf seine persönliche
individuelle entwicklung
blumenbach ganz wichtig da lesen wir
auch diesen diese schrift über den
bildungsweg
dann als nächsten den kennt sie alle wer
ist das kennen sie den
kennen sie geld den kennen sie das ist
friedrich schiller nicht
es ist natürlich günter grass auch nicht
es ist goethe und zwar von goethe und
goethe hat sich auch auf diesen bildung
streep bezogen ich habe seine ganzen
werke digital und ich habe heute mal ein
bisschen die durchsucht da gibt es
einige stellen wohl auch bildung streep
drin vorkommt ja also sie wissen alle
die metamorphose sind leere kennen sie
die metamorphose lehre schreibt
metamorphose das ist auch hier so ein
bisschen bildung organismus metamorphose
also ein wesen ein natürliches wesen vor
allem ein tier aber auch andere die sich
da um formen plötzlich formen lehre die
formen lehre goethes formen leben
morphologie ja denken sie an aristoteles
sie haben hier die möglichkeit und die
wirklichkeit die dynamik und die energie
ja das stimmt auch historisches modell
dahinter einfach diese dynamik der natur
entwicklung und hier bei goethe schauen
was zu diesem bildung streep sagt
natürlich immer auch nicht nur der blick
auf die natur sind immer auch mit blick
auf den mensch weil der mensch ist ja in
den meisten fällen dieser denker ein
teil der natur
insofern kanada auch in die kontinuität
gestellt werden jetzt haben wir diesen
herrn dirk erkennen sie ihn ist ein sehr
realistisches bildnis das ist also kein
stilisiert das bildnis das immanuel kant
und der soll einer unserer schwerpunkte
bilden wenn sie meinen seminarplan
schauen hat in jeder von ihnen oder
brauchte noch jemand hinten seminarplan
hier
wenn sie meine seminarplan schauen die
uns übrigens auch online finden auch
philo cast und in der app natürlich auch
das sehen sie jetzt hier sind wir
angekommen bei kann sechste sitzung der
kriegt zwei sätzen
sechste sitzung und siebter sitzung ist
für ihn reserviert und zwar deswegen bei
kant eben an verschiedenen stellen
seines sehr umfangreichen werkes von
trieb sprechen einmal spricht der von
bloßen trieben im sinne verneigungen von
bedürfnissen begehungen und so und
einmal spricht er von triebfedern
triebfedern
darüber habe ich auch ein bisschen
referiert in meinem vortrag triebfeder
eine triebfeder ist so was wie eine
motivation eigentlich kann spricht von
den triebfedern des willens
also was motiviert den willen zur
handlung wille zur handlung und das ist
eben kann ganz verschiedenes seien nach
kant nach kann gibt es nur zwei mögliche
triebfeder des willens einmal die natur
oder unsere neigungen dass die hetero
nomi die fremdbestimmung eben durch
unsere betriebe
das ist dann die hetero nomi als die
fremdbestimmung
das will kant gerade nicht einmal die
bestimmung des willens die triebfeder
der vernunft die rationale motivation
unseres willens und das ist dann
verkannt die autonomie die alles selbst
gesetzgebung und das ist das was kann
gerade zeigen möchte wie so etwas
möglich ist also zwei triebfedern des
willens wir haben lange darüber
diskutiert auf der tagung erstens mal
wie kann man triebfeder am besten setzen
ins englische driving force spring die
bei einer feder die springfehler oder
eher incentive also anreiz ein motiv
oder driving force ja also es ganz
verschiedene möglichkeiten gibt es auf
jeden fall steht hier fest dass
triebfeder so eine mechanische
mechanistische metaphorik enthält eine
triebfeder
atlas wie von einer maschine wie bei
einer uhr und wir funktionieren nicht
wie maschinen ja also auch problematisch
wir wollen aber da uns ein bisschen
näher mit befassen
dann haben wir mit diesem netten herren
sicher zu tun mit kennen sie
wahrscheinlich nicht der ist recht
unbekannt haben sie eine idee
naja wenn sie mit anschauen wie es
werden dieses finden sofort dieses kann
die un hat reinhold darüber habe ich ihm
auch referiert und calyon hat reinhold
ist ein sogenannter ja kann tiana als
einer der ganz philosophie die ja
unglaublich wirkmächtig war sie müssen
sich das wirklich vorstellen wie ein
ganz großes ereignis die kantige
philosophie es war also wirklich total
im trend der zeit die waren alle total
verrückt danach und waren fast schon so
kleine anhänger und reinhold hat eben
diese kann tische philosophie
popularisiert hat sie verbreitet und er
hat sie versucht verständlicher zu
machen weil wenn sich schon einmal
erkannt gelesen haben werden sie
feststellen
es ist unglaublich schwierig zu
verstehen er schreibt nicht sonderlich
klar und reinhold hat versucht das eben
klare und verständliche darzustellen und
bei diesem versuch das ganze klarer und
verständlicher darzustellen hat reinhold
natürlich auch die eine oder andere
umdeutung seiner theorie vorgenommen
also reinhold macht das nicht so dass er
einfach alles eins zu eins übersetzt in
so eine leichtere verständlichere
sprache sondern in der übersetzung kommt
es zu einer umdeutung zu einer
interpretation und die interpretation
betrifft unter anderem oder aber auch
ganz zentral den kantischen trieb
begriff als wären kann verkannt der
trieb begriff keine große rolle spielt
nur der begriff die triebfeder wird der
trieb jetzt wird sich bei reinhold ganz
wichtig und reinhold spricht von einem
eigennützigen und einem uneigennützigen
trieb davon hätte kann nie gesprochen so
was kennt kann überhaupt nicht aber
reinhold glaubt eben diese triebfedern
lehre bei kant so interpretieren zu
können als gäbe ist ein eigennützigen
trieb und einen uneigennützigen trieb so
zwei ursprünglich antriebe in uns die
fest in uns verwurzelt
so wie dieser platonische mythos davon
dessen pferd da haben wir mit diesem
herrn jetzt tun
den kennen sie bestimmt auch sehr
markant friedrich schiller und schiller
bezieht sich auch stark auf kant und auf
reinheit und schiller kennt jetzt nicht
nur zwei triebe sonne 3 als er kennt den
form trieb den stoff trieb und welchen
trieb noch wissen sie es ja ihr hattet
spieltrieb den spieltrieb also genauso
vortrieb ist der vernünftige trieb und
der stoff trieb ist er der irrationale
trieb könnte man sagen dann gibt es auch
den spieltrieb und der spieltrieb
vermittelt zwischen dem form träger
einen vernünftigen trieb und dem stoff
dreht reform trieb strebt nach dem
ewigen nach dem rationalen nach der
ordnung und schülersprecher an manchen
stellen auch so dass der stoff triebs
und ableben streep ist also ihr die
natur das nicht so ganz rational das
nicht so ganz geordnete und jetzt wie
sie diese wiesen schiller sein ganz
großer harmonie ist harmonika an so
schiller erträgt das nicht wenn der
mensch zerrissen ist sie kennen
vielleicht seine schriften über anmut
und würde also schüler möchte dass wir
wenn wir ethisch handeln dass wir nicht
gezwungen handeln das ist eine große
großer vorwurf gegenüber kant kants
kategorischer imperativ der absolut
gebietet nach kann sind wir wenn wir
moralisch handeln und einem zwang der
vernunft und dann sagt schiller
das können kann zwar moralisch sein aber
darüber steht noch die schöne handlung
nicht nur die moralischen und die schöne
handlung und die schöne handlung
vollzieht sich so dass sie moralisch gut
ist aber darin noch harmonisch ist dass
wir in der schönen handlung und handel
aber nicht gezwungen sondern darin ganz
frei ausgeglichen und deswegen nimmt
schiller auch noch einen dritten trieb
an nämlich noch den spieltrieb neben dem
vertrieb und dem stoff trinken
um diese zwei triebe durch die wir wenn
es sie nur gebe zerrissen wären
miteinander zu vermitteln ganz spannende
frage können uns immer fragen wenn wir
die ganzen denke jetzt behandelt erstens
wie viele triebe kennen sie ja kennen
sie nur einen trieb können sie 23
bekennen sie drei triebe und wie
verhalten sich die verschiedenen triebe
zueinander
das ist auch eine ganz ganz wichtige
frage die wir uns stellen müssen und
diese frage betrifft dann das system der
jeweiligen denke es gibt gute gründe
eben nicht nur einen trieb anzunehmen
sondern zwei
weil der mensch und zwischen wesen ist
der mensch hat einerseits seine ganz
animalische seite an sich der mensch hat
aber auch rationale anteil er ist nicht
nur triebhaft er ist ein bisschen mehr
als nur ein tier also wir kommen jetzt
sofort auf die anthropologie und so
könnte man das jetzt belassen
man könnte man sich fragen aber
vielleicht reflektieren wir doch noch
mal auf beide triebe sowie dieser
wagenlenker bei platow dieser wagen
lenken könnte als dritter trieb
dargestellt werden als mit antrieb oder
als trieb zweiter ordnung der sich auf
die triebe erste stufe die sich
irgendwie entgegengesetzt sind bezieht
ich kann das mal so ein bisschen hier
grafisch veranschaulichen
ich mach mal den händlern wir hier weg
also sie haben sozusagen hier zwei
verschiedene betriebe die sind
gewissermaßen entgegengesetzt
und dann haben sie hier noch mal einen
dritten trieb hier irgendwie
erstens zweitens drittens um diese
dritte betrieb muss vermitteln muss so
denkt das ganze jedenfalls schiller
spielte dann haben wir diesen jahren
jetzt schon wissen sie wir das ist die
johann gottlieb fichte und bei fichte
ist es ganz interessant für fichte wird
der trieb ganz zentralen seiner
philosophie fichte spricht von einem
system der triebe also der fichte wieder
trieb so richtig auf gewährt während er
bei kant er so gefährlich war und so das
prinzip der hetero nomi bedeutet hatte
wird er zum verpflichtet das prinzip des
systems das prinzip der freiheit das
prinzip des selbstbewusstseins
ja warum das müssen wir uns genau
erfragen und bei fichte werden wir
feststellen dass er auch einen dritten
trieb ansetzt den er aber nicht den
spieltrieb nennen soll in einer schrift
name frühen schriften ästhetischen trieb
oder gab es eine ganz große debatte
zwischen schiller und fichte schüler war
in jeder redakteur einer zeitschrift
waren die [ __ ] die ohren und schlichte
wollte einen aufsatz in diesen rohren
veröffentlichen und schiller hat dieser
aufsatz nicht gefallen schiller war er
redakteur und schüler hat diesen auf
märz abgelehnt haben es zu einem
zerwürfnis zwischen beiden wird diese
frage nach der anzahl der triebe danach
derart dieses dritten vereinigenden
triebes wir wollen also fragen wie
verhält sich zb fichtes ästhetischer
trieb zudem schillers spieltrieb ja also
worin unterscheiden sie sich warum
könnte schiller fichte streep abgelehnt
haben sich des ästhetischen so was
könnten sie zum beispiel auch zum thema
im haus arbeiten macht
also schiller oder fichte könnten sie
sich fragen wer hat die besseren
argumente auf seiner seite
achte schiller recht gute gründe wie ich
das auf satz abzunehmen
nur als beispiel nennen sie den hier
schilling ich kenne die schellingstraße
ist da ihm benannt schelling ist so eine
art hausgeist der lmu münchen überall
präsent straßen akademien in den
seminaren schelling hat sich auch mit
dem trieb beschäftigt vielleicht nicht
so sehr wie mit dem begriff des willens
der willens begriff ist für schilling
vielleicht noch ein bisschen wichtiger
haber schilling hat eine ganz wichtige
naturphilosophie verfasst und auch
schelling versucht eben die menschliche
existenz in ihrer lebendigkeit zu denken
die konkrete existenz zu fassen deswegen
muss er sich auch mit dem trieb begriff
beschäftigen kann man jedenfalls hier
eine sitzung während wir verzichten wie
sie sie dem seminarplan zwei sitzungen
eingeplant haben sich da haben wir zwei
sitzungen gegeben
bis ins neue jahr sowohl kelly ist ist
der nächste denker nicht weit nämlich
georg wilhelm friedrich hegel und hegel
hat ein system entwickelt wie fichte
aber für hegel spielt der begriff des
triebes jetzt nicht mehr eine rolle als
motiv eines objekts
also ich habe das immer mit einem
subjekt zu tun oder einem individuum so
ein hegel denkt den trieb im sinne einer
logik der begriffe also vorher dürfen
sie sich den trieb nicht mehr vorstellen
in bezug auf einen subjekte auf ein
individuum was angetrieben wird ja nicht
da dürfen sie nicht wie so ein
psychisches psyche habe ich noch
vergessen psyche und seele
so dürfen sie sich den trieb bei hegel
nicht mehr vorstellen als so ein motiv
oder sowas psychologisches während bei
schiller und so dass durchaus in die
anthropologische und psychologische
anthropologie hineingeht und bei hegel
ist der trieb ein logisches
als eine rein logische bestimme die in
einem system des absoluten wie hegels
nennt eine ganz bestimmte funktionen
eine ganz bestimmte rolle und das
absolute hat nach hegel auch einen trieb
jetzt wird's spannend dass wir uns
genauer fragen regelt denkt eben den
trieb nicht mehr vom subjekt hier nicht
mehr vom individuum er nicht mehr von
der individuellen existenz wie es alle
vorherigen denker getan hatten
verwickelt wird der trieb zu einer
logischen einem logischen moment in
einem ganzen system von bedeutungen die
aufeinander organisch aufbauen
natürlich können sich vorstellen wenn
man so ein großes organisches system hat
braucht man auch so etwas bewegen des
darin das muss eine bewegung geben denkt
die begriffe immer in bewegung
die substanz als subjekt sagte das
absolute muss als etwas dynamisches
gedacht werden dann können sich schon
vorstellen dass der betrieb auch
irgendwie vorkommen muss
durch die dynamik oder die dialektik
haben sie auch schon mal gehört
dialektik ist so ein motor diese ganze
entwicklung und woher bekommen die
dialektik ihre kraft sich dazu bewegen
kann man schon so ein bisschen ahnend
dass der betrieb auch ein spiel kommen
das ist jetzt eine erste fotografie
kleine daguerreotypie wissen sie wir das
ist ganz klar
autor schopenhauer und auch bei
schopenhauer ist es ähnlich wie bei
schelling schopenhauer spricht er vom
wille ein werk geschrieben die welt als
wille und vorstellung und da kommt der
trieb jetzt nicht so prominenten vor
muss man schon sagen aber dennoch wollen
wir eben schopenhauer nicht außen vor
lassen wenn sie auf der tagung waren
haben sie vielleicht gemerkt da kamen
schopenhauer man nicht vor wir werden
aber für den sammelband den wir jetzt
planen noch einen weiteren beitrag mit
hinzunehmen überschritten habe
und wenn die zeit reicht zimmer nämlich
eigentlich schon durch laut seminarplan
aber wenn die zeit reichen sollte wäre
ich noch offen entweder für nietzsche
oder freud wer möchte nietzsche einfach
mal melden
wer möchte freut also wenn die zeit
reicht dann machen wir noch freut dazu
das führt mich jetzt zurück zur eingangs
thematik nach der bitte
sagen
also das geht eigentlich in die richtung
von schopenhauer also nietzsche wie auch
schopenhauer nietzsche freud bild
verdanken schopenhauer sehr viel freud
hat mal gesagt dass er schopenhauer dass
er bei der lektüre von schopenhauer auf
seine trieb lehre kam hat freut gesagt
und nietzsche ist ein ganz großer
anhänger von schopenhauer also also es
stehen irgendwie im schatten oder in
abhängigkeit von schopenhauer
deswegen müssen wir schon schopenhauer
unbedingt nehmen ob genetische und
freude unbedingt nehmen müssen ist die
frage aber ich glaube dass wir nico und
freud in die große tradition der
klassischen deutschen philosophie
stellen können es ist jetzt eben an
unseren punkt warum habe ich jetzt das
seminar nicht genannt der begriff des
triebes im deutschen sozialismus
wissen sie wie man den deutschen
idealismus bestimmt man beginnt der
deutsche idealismus und hörte auf
vorschläge es gibt keine eindeutige
definition häufig genau häufig sagt man
von kant bis hegel
aber was es mit schopenhauer der wird
dann rausfallen schopenhauer war nach
start nach hegel
tja ist mit job mache aber schopenhauer
jetzt doch ganz klar beeinflusst von
kant wenn sie die die welt als wille und
vorstellung lesen finden sie ganz viele
bezüge zu kant also sehen der begriff
deutsche idealismus ist schwierig zumal
auch schon deswegen weil das ist den
idealismus
die wollten da keine idealisten
unbedingt sein sondern die wollten eine
realismus vertreten teilweise manchmal
haben sie ihre werke idealismus genannt
als system des trans cent an idealismus
aber reinhold wollten realist zu sichern
also der begriff des idealismus ist
völlig unklar und kant hat sein system
zwar auch trans zentrale idealismus
genannt aber sie sehen idealismus ist
nur so ein label und dann kann man sich
wirklich fragen warum nicht schopenhauer
noch mit hinzunehmen
genauso kann man sich fragen ja beginnt
das wirklich mit kant oder beginnt es
nicht eigentlich schon vor kant und also
der die bezeichnung klassischen
deutschen philosophie
wie fast das ganze aber noch weiter auf
das bedeutet einfach nur ganz offen
einfach die deutschen philosophen
deutschsprachigen die einfach die
wichtigsten waren und es war damals
ebenso ständig es mir jedenfalls vorne
ziemlich große rezeptions leistung auch
deswegen weil sie eben alle dieselbe
sprache gesprochen haben das heißt du
musst sie keine übersetzung machen von
david hume zum beispiel die ganze
empirische tradition musste man ja nur
konnte man nur über übersetzungen
bekommen aus zweiter hand klassische
deutsche philosophie konnte alles aus
erster hand haben
natürlich muss man dazusagen leibnitz
der häufig gottfried wilhelm leibniz der
häufig auch zur klassischen deutschen
philosophie zielt und vor kant geliebt
hatte leibnitz hat sehr häufig noch auf
latein geschrieben ist eben immanuel
kant hat zwar auch auf latein was
geschrieben seine doktorarbeit aber er
hat die kritik der reinen vernunft hat
er auf deutsch geschrieben und gibt es
andere philosophen wie baumgarten wie
wolf und so weiter die auch häufig noch
auf latein geschrieben haben und herder
wie sieht es mit hertha aus hertha hat
vor kant gelebt aber er war auch ein
großer aufklärungs denke man könnte zum
beispiel sagen die klassische
philosophie ist eine große tradition der
aufklärung gut wie sieht es dann mit
schopenhauer aus schopenhauers
philosophie der aufklärung ist nicht
schön für das auf der aufklärung sehen
ist ganz schwierig mit diesem label habe
ich für ich bevorzuge den begriff
klassischen deutschen philosophie
einfach weil er weiter ist man die
bezüge vor und nach vor kant und nach
hegel offen hält ja aber es ist es eine
strittige sei somit schopenhauer oder
nietzsche oder freud enden wir haben sie
noch fragen zu diesen denkt an jetzt
haben wir die hälfte dessen der sitzung
es jetzt tun
das war jetzt der inhaltliche teilen der
heutigen ersten genau gesagt zweiten
sitzung
haben sie noch fragen zum inhaltlichen
war jetzt komme ich nämlich in der
zweiten hälfte zum formalen